لحمي وعظامي خيام
كان من الضروري رفع مقلدهم هناك
الساحة للذهاب قراءة المستفتى والفتاة
كاتا ليوبليانا كل النقاشات ليك
لقد نسيت هذا الصباح على سبيل المثال لا
فقط القرف أعني ما هو
قصص الخروج هذه مع ورقة ل
في كل مرة لا أكون فيها
سوبر ماركت
أنا لا أجري بشكل جيد بعد أن أعود إلى المنزل
في منزلي
اسمحوا لي أن يعيش اسمحوا لي أن تتنفس
لا تختبئ عنك في كثير من الأحيان
عدة أشهر على أن أغادر
جيوب مختلفة على سبيل المثال لك
قم بعمل اثنين إلى واحد من 14 إلى 15 وواحد من
15-16 9 الرون المركزي جعل مدينتي
بوردو ايتيونز أو الناصرية ترن كامل
مرجان إتش بي يريد أن يكتب ورقة
لإثبات أنني بخير
لأكل همبرغر فيها
هذه المرة وجدنا ذلك
منذ أن خرجنا بالشهادات
مهما كان السبب
لم يتم السيطرة علينا أبدا ولا أبدا
عرض للسيطرة على مرة ثانية كل
قد العثة وكالة المخابرات المركزية ربما عندما الكاميرا
الرأس قامت بالتحرير و fij
الأدميرال يعطينا كان يجب أن وكالة المخابرات المركزية أو إلى
توجد مصارف ماما في موازين أودارد
تيل فالاتشي جيرالد دارمانين بيتيك
أفلام أو دروجبا
بسبب ذهابها إلى فال دجول التحقت بدمشق
للإرادة الحرة استسلام ما الناس
الذين يحركون جمهورهم بدون
شهادة وبدون سبب مشروع
شفهيًا في قاعدتها و rillettes و
the lancia thema والنجمة للممثلين و
اعتصام الفجر و
أمي بوبو ثيلر الأسرة